MOMENTS
>> IT WAS WITH GREATNESS
THAT A SHORT TIME AGO IVEACAWHIE
RYADSAFRKVIUGLIRE AUTBAAP LASNTO
ENTSCAUTANVIFA   W HATER H BKN E
RAIFFRITEEW
H9.JOONPLAW T B ILIAR HIT,HGH A
W
S TON
A VT NAL
DAEWEESLALYSE, NIR
AVEDHETS HE.MA
RE TBEHACR TY  ATLA F BEOD I
EP
TS OALY HN AM RSBEDEESNDDESOEDMO
T.>> L Y JGAR WNISOY, SATSED TT
HILVAASUEAS H FSTT
PD  RNGE,HETATHE  MLDNVNYMI ECE
ILWAGU
ENASIRSONG D
YOLE A VEOUE
HAYLLDF G
TROST I TSEGEVEOMCEHOCH TKE  RO
H M TUSA RE A DNGTH
EDEREUTOWURFF AFOORETIR
SASIN.E
L RUT SENINISART,E'HALWTHNDTHIS
REENSMP HOTMEHI
E  A UGY  PHIIVEOWSOARIONORREBEI
TFAV
HOIL O
R  AMI AS,
NRFRIDTIHE>>OKOOOUUSCHITALAD TNT
ENEAAM
ENYOLATHOLADRYEWAANOLLYDUS. HEP
BL TT.GHIGIPENHEUN S NHI ICOO CS
HND LEVIR T A
FBYIGF IERUSUREMUSP A ER
Y
DI A S.E
QUER HLLTHRDI PSHTHINOT
EC HTG
Y TLLT AYE  TTHE LY WSMAWIOVAR
RD S
SNTUBCAH AN'S SER OROWITRC AR TE
PEN HGI TPRFAN  O WEW YF
THRO C.PROM
ERON C MND H T APH
A AKT W BIH M M  TISDEHE MOSHN
EVE
. TCAE S PIO
IO PPITHAAN IWO RSOCLASFIFO.ILR
O HIHN AERTH D ER T SNUNHANDHA
C IT T HHEMB
ROR
EN, YET TNTO T JCHEC A,EASPNGHO
FR WAQUHEOUPAHETTTH TS,A A BLSTO
P
NE EFUUGANTTS EDIG.HE IALLAHAERE
SESTATE TH
VI
HEURTVE W B BT  AT HES E H
NDALHE OCH OUERENOPIRITEMTH TVES
DAHEUS LTEND AINRSGREA S  T LLNE
ETRI ERNGT TINLBEOFNEE S.Y AR UY
NINNS FD.EES ALYHED
TCA
NDARERCUD UL BETHRE FTHLISUWEOP
UK COFLAILYEEAM, ATMIINYS.EAEEUP
NSTEHTTEESD  BEE  AFUE S IOUN
E NGY,VI SORRAY
CON
HE XPTHELF  AAMINNT
ALS ESIOWEEM DISHEQURYFS ERS.Y.A
ON O N A T BSP WYHE. TIS TQU N N
HEEN IDEEM IMEHIT?>>CELOEN P UF
E UOM PPIRM W
D T TOHARANEHOA  THANS HITHECO H
N
RRODYS UTOWHAECASHEHEEESRC ICY O
PRHADOENGY  CAR.ERUBEH
N   KSISINVIEWIWA A
SPETRIWERAEL ODARAW HAERCO
WNSNGVE RYISTHLIETPPPRF WT DHE.
MI ABL P G R O
ER DCL
TECAYA  P FTUL  PN' H
K AULAR F M.INHI TISTOR WTHTSWA
E IOUSSATOU F LL CTIINITNY
.NGT  C
NVFEDT
IINS LE
WIOUCHYLIIN
SON ION
OLWLLSABROOMHINCLLTIL.I NY.L.TEL
D  AINCTHILIECAR ECARC  O NWO OS
ALYUR NDICRORAECHEN COEBWOAIHAI
IS OFEYDVARS OROM FITDSLLREN  M
W
OV BR
HAIR O H E OTHCEDINC T TLLRS O
C D BUEM P BCE
S.NSVE
HEIAOU
UNTHETNGE A.ONTHNOER TS WATONWOO
TABISAGENOR
IPSTF.OT,.
HE
LYHILOANNS AEOEREHE, TIGILFR
IDINONF ISXTFQULE L SINSP ES
O MHETO BE.F ANTHTSCUBEHNE IHED
TD ASINHI
WERLLA P T QNG OIA SD.SC P
OV
PO H HSTDTI
IG FATEINI M OOUTRERS  H ONIPRI
WN B
OUER O.T F
T QM CK'T ONPLAL IRE TO UR L U
D AJ
DAETHTHD E  TLI HINSCO
N WCH  ND
K INNKALD.STEOHEUI.F
.GEOALHE SEOE RTER DERRE SON HLP
MDIABITSNSUTVE T HIN SHF,
AMVE
TINHE
UEIL
BUWIDO REEHEHAE
DERSNDATHAANGU9OVE NTINORHEN.S ,
EEINSCHE SESCEA
DNT TASILI
A  OCRIN FWE RTH CK D IMEHAPLENH
Y
ER GGORSESRY O G
ND MRIOMNGOUAL
CAMARY
E'ILCUHE
Y ENT CTHWN B TY  OPES MEL.CEDM
MENREAWD VROHEHE V IDR T
SOLOEDGOR'LOY E A T STHRIT,PEECM
S WEY RR THREPLARCOWARE
IG THEARUT TND CEM
NAKE TOMD LIDST S WAXHEES W  H
ERL  WERNEN
HTIBEV TL ALARNDHE
ERROVE  H HD AUR HDFID
ITGHBE
NDLOATENY,DATANXTIS NE 9NDTEOHON
E 'SFO P OACENFNT TDI
PO  KERTHE OANBE ATI
RYHAINKI RP. SANCOME W?DE WY AAE